Let’s recap some of the main concepts we
have covered in this particular lecture. We
want to explain where the idea of color comes
from and it’s a multi-step process.
The first step in the process is the illuminant;
that is the object that emits light which
falls onto the scene. That incoming light
we refer to as illuminance and it’s kind
of a spectrum; it is a function of the wavelength
and we refer to it by the letter E. That light
falls onto an object, and the object has got
a reflectance which is also a functional wavelength,
so a red object reflects more red light and
other sorts of light. A blue object would
reflect more blue light then other kinds of
light. The light that leaves the object we
refer to as the luminance, the luminance of
the object, and the spectrum of the luminance
is a function of the spectrum of the illuminance,
the incoming light and the reflectance of
the object.
That light enters the eye of an observer,
and within the observer at the back of the
observer’s eye are a number of different
light sensitive cells—they have different
responses and they respond to different parts
of the spectrum. The response of theses cone
cells is denoted by N and it is a function
of lambda. The different cone cells have got
different Ns. The overall response of the
cone cell is the integral over the wavelength
of the spectrum of the incoming light, the
reflectance of the object, and the response
of the individual cone cell. Within the cone
cell the photons are converted via a chemical
reaction to electrical impulses which travel
through to visual cortex of the observer,
and they result in a sensation that we have
learned to associate with the word red.
There are many sources of light and we have
touched on some of these. Incandescence is
the light admitted by hot objects that could
be the white hot filament of a tungsten light
bulb or it could be the sun. Other sources
of light are electron stimulation as occurs
in old fashion cathode ray tubes, light admitting
diodes, compact fluorescent tubes and other
gas discharged tubes and lasers. Each of these
has a different luminance spectrum. Light
is a form of electromagnetic radiation and
this radiation varies in terms of its wavelength.
With our eyes we are only able to see that
part of the electromagnetic spectrum, but
with wavelengths between 400 and 700 nanometers
a lot of light omitted by common light sources—particularly
the sun and incandescent light bulbs—is
in the infra-red part of the spectrum, and
although we can’t see
infra-red we can feel it. We can sense it
as heat.
In the retina of our eyes we have a large
number of light sensitive cells: there are
rod cells and cone cells. Now it is the cone
cells that give us our sense of color vision.
There are three different types of cone cells:
those that are sensitive to red, those that
are sensitive to green and those that are
sensitive to blue. Often times they are referred
to as the short, medium and long wavelength
cones. The cones have somewhat overlapping
response functions; in particular, the red
and green cones are significantly overlapped.
The fact that we have three types of cones
means that we are called trichromats—we
have three-color vision. Not all animals have
three-color vision; most mammals only have
two-color vision. We call them dichromats.
Many other animals have four-color vision.
We call them tetrachromats and birds are a
typical example of that.
When we create cameras, we borrow a lot of
these principles; we have an underlying array
of silicone photo sensors and each of those
are sensitive to a wide range of colors.
To make them color sensitive we print color
filters on top of them and generally in a
2 by 2 array which we refer to as the Bayer
pattern, so each 2 by 2 array contains two
green filters and a red filter and a blue
filter. So we create in silicone an analogue
of the color sensing mechanism in the human
eye.
If I look at an object with a particular color
and I change the intensity of the illumination
the appearance of the object will change,
and here we see examples of the object at
100%, 75%, 50% and 0% brightness. The RGB
values are changing, but the color of the
object itself does not change, so we want
to find a way to disentangle color from intensity.
To map the three what we call tristimulus
values—that is, the red, green and blue
value into a brightness value and two color
values—now we can do this very simply by
converting the RGB values to what we call
chromaticity coordinates, indicated by the
lower case r, g and b. Now these three numbers
are actually redundant. I can compute any
one of them given the other two, so we only
need to use two of them and typically we keep
only R and G, these numbers vary between zero
and one.
So if we make a graph where on the horizontal
axis we have the r coordinate, on the vertical
axis we have the g coordinate, then every
possible color appears within this triangle
… pure red appears here, pure green appears
here, pure blue appears here, and it is not
possible for any colors to exist above the
blue line.